what's interesting is the biden
administration has come to south dakota
and said listen you either let boys play
in girls sports or we're going to
withhold school lunches which i think is
the craziest thing i've ever heard i
mean not only does this administration
not care about solving our baby formula
issue but then they go and threaten to
take away food from children to create
an unfair situation for women so they're
going after women children and babies
and it's hard for me to believe that
anybody supports the democrat party
anymore after what joe biden is doing
it's it's amazing to me that to
have this kind of a
left extremist agenda that they would go
after women and children and literally
threaten taking away taking away food in
their schools
so speaking of sports actually we've got
a good transition there one of the other
things you've been leading on is
actually keeping boys and girls in
separate sports leagues and it's okay
and it's not based in bigotry or
anything else are you shocked that this
even got to your desk and and that you
had to kind of lead on this thing
because everyone's talking about it now
but you were really doing this it's
almost two years ago at this point
we know i started this fight probably
five years ago you know people don't
remember this but when i was in congress
the federal government came down and
told south dakota that we could no
longer have girls events and boys events
in the sport of rodeo which you know a
lot of people don't pay attention to
rodeo so it never made national news but
to south dakota that was a really big
deal it's our state sport
and they told us that it was too
discriminatory to have a girls event and
a boys event and that we had to
eliminate all gender references in that
sport statewide
and i fought them i
fought them alone
nobody really cared at that time about
this issue or they thought it was too
politically dangerous to really wade
into
but ended up winning that argument at
that time so this is something i'd been
a part of fighting for many many years
when it came to protecting girls sports
now that it's a national issue
i wanted the strongest bill in the
nation in the state of south dakota
because i know that
this is a basic fairness issue this is
about only girls playing in girls sports
so they have an opportunity to be
successful and to succeed maybe win a
scholarship go on and play
professionally if that opportunity
presents itself and that biological
males should not be playing in their
same events but
it's interesting to me to watch the kind
of attacks that have come
just because uh you know this it serves
a political agenda for us in south
dakota i know that as soon as we passed
a bill that was going to be put into
statute it would be challenged in court
and i did not want to pass a flawed bill
that made us vulnerable to having it
overturned and setting up incredible
precedent that would leave us in a
situation where i wouldn't be able to
enforce
uh this rule in our state and be in a
situation where we would always have to
have boys playing in girls sports so i'm
proud of the bill we passed it was
something i authored and the legislature
supported and now south dakota is the
state that that has the most
strongest and
court challenged um you know will
withstand a court challenged the best in
the nation are there court cases about
that right now i mean just in the last
couple weeks we one of the things we've
covered here is that uh the federal
government wants to come after states
that pass bills like this and
potentially withhold school lunches from
kids in states that do things like this
so you're going to punish the kids who
have nothing to do with this i mean
right it's typical of everything going
on with this government but yeah you're
exactly right you know there there isn't
court challenges right now although if
we had done flawed bills then they would
have used that opportunity to undermine
them and set up precedent but yes what's
interesting is the biden administration
has come to south dakota and said listen
you either let boys play in girls sports
or we're going to withhold school
lunches which i think is the craziest
thing i've ever heard i mean not only
does this administration
not care about solving our baby formula
issue but then they go and threaten to
take away food from children to create
an unfair situation for women so they're
going after women children and babies
and it's hard for me to believe that
anybody supports the democrat party
anymore after what joe biden is doing
it's it's amazing to me that to
have this kind of a
left extremist agenda that they would go
after women and children and literally
threaten taking away taking away food in
their schools
you mentioned tom daschle before who was
a democrat so did i mean when you had a
guy like him who you obviously had some
disagreements with when you were younger
of course but he i don't think he was
like a crazy crazy lefty the way they
seem to be now do you have a sense of
how that shifted maybe how it shifted in
your state and i think everyone can sort
of see it at a national level at this
point i would say that at the time he
was serving you know he would have been
a more moderate democrat and south
dakota elects a lot of democrats to
federal level people tend to think of
south dakota as a very conservative
state and that's just not necessarily
true when we elect officials to
washington d.c
you know
tom was what people probably would call
more of a
blue dog democrat you know maybe
cooperated with republicans a little bit
more it did catch up with him some of
his votes and his way of life but when i
ran for congress i ran against a
democrat
that had a very high approval rating in
the state of south dakota it was a very
tough race one of the top five races in
the nation at that time and even my last
race
running for governor here in south
dakota i only won that race by three
points and
it was to a democrat who embraced bernie
sanders
policies so
you know i think a lot of people see the
conservative things that are going on in
south dakota and think wow well that's
easy to do in a red state like that well
we're we're getting more and more red
all the time but but there's been a lot
of democrats that have been elected in
south dakota and they got elected by
being more populist rather than
the extreme far left that we see in the
country right now do you see a parallel
between south dakota and florida in that
you know desantis who's now crushing it
here and you guys have many of the same
policies
um you know he only won by 30 000 votes
and it turns out that the guy he beat
he became a meth addict or
or maybe maybe was a math addict at the
time
but but the point being that you guys
both won pretty close races and the
country could look very very different
if you know south dakota and florida had
turned blue i mean it radically would
yeah i think i think so you know ron and
i got elected to congress the same year
we served for eight years together in
the house and both ran for governor at
the same time we both have very
different states but we do have higher
than average elderly populations so that
all got taken into account when we were
making our decisions as well recognizing
we had a higher ratio ratio of our
population that would be vulnerable but
at the end of the day i think we made
the decisions that were best for our
people we still made very different
decisions you know he had some closures
at different times different mandates
but but i do think that every governor
it's it's easy for people to pass
judgment
on on them from the outside two or three
years later
i will say that for every single
governor it was a it was a difficult
time every decision was hard
so you've been ahead on a couple things
we talked about covet obviously and some
of the gender stuff one of the other
things you've been talking about is food
security
and for my audience obviously doesn't
watch much mainstream media but they are
paying attention to what's going on
online i mean every day there are new
headlines about uh you know meat uh
producing fields and all of these things
that are that are on fire factories seem
to be burning up that our our food
security really seems to be threatened
right now there was this weird thing in
kansas with 2 000 cattle dying out of
nowhere supposedly from heat what what
is going on here
well i've been talking about food
security as a national security issue
for 15 years
i served on a committee
in the state of course i am a farmer and
a rancher that's how i've made my living
my entire life until i got involved in
government and politics but
beyond that i served on a committee that
oversaw the federal farm programs in the
state but i recognized that america has
always embraced a food policy of having
it be diversified
in in the country so that one person
doesn't control our food supply that
many different farmers and small
businesses do and processors but that
also
we have had a cheap food policy we
wanted every single family in this
country to be able to afford to put food
on the table for their families
and i've been drawing attention for 15
years to the fact that we are losing
both of those
battles that we have we have more and
more foreign countries buying up our
processing systems they're buying up our
fertilizer companies our chemical
companies our processing facilities
not only is china manipulating their
currency but stealing our ip building up
their military they're also buying our
land
they own a lot of our food supply chain
system and when another country controls
our food
that is when they control us if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell